the hippies didn't much like the
beatniks and they really hated the punks
punks didn't much like the hippies and
they really hated the hardcore kids so
it's just been a cycle I think of
Bohemians hating each other
hi I'm Anthony Fisher for recent TV and
I'm with Ada Calhoun the author of st.
marks is dead the many lives of
America's hippest Street which is a
loving study of the three blocks or so
in the East Village of Manhattan from
pre-colonial times to the present day
ada has written for the new york times
magazine was a crime reporter for New
York Post and actually grew up on st.
Mark's Place during an era when it
wasn't exactly kid-friendly Edith thanks
so much for talking to us for having me
I feel like the book makes st. marks out
to be a microcosm of eccentric America
and everyone from the first post Civil
War black musical performers to 20th
century anarchists communists the beats
hippies punks skaters they all had their
time on st. marks what is it about those
three or four blacks is it something in
the water people told me it's like
there's a ley line or one of those
psychic mr. cool streams underneath it
in the early 1900's it was a big spot
for union headquarters there were all
these different unions like a ship
builders and the pipe fitters they were
all along st. Mark's Place and so then
it was just as gathering spot for
revolutionaries so since then I mean I
think then it had this reputation and
everybody who came there came there for
the reputation and then felt like it was
an obligation to keep that reputation
going is there anything that's kind of
stayed the same are there any
institutions or personality traits about
the neighborhood of they've stayed the
same at least for the last hundred years
well I think even going back further
it's always been a place for runaways so
starting with Peter Stuyvesant who was
the Dutch director-general back in the
1600s and he really hated that there
were so many prostitutes and pirates at
the tip of the island and what was then
you know that the middle of town so he
started this Bowery farm up and what was
then way up in the country what of
course is now downtown Manhattan your
roots that some of the first quote
unquote Bohemians of the 1960s were
actually posers who were eating french
caricature of gypsy culture were they
able to create any authentic culture of
their own or was it all just opposed
well I think the line between posers and
authentic bohemian says you know it's
pretty thin I think depending on which
side of it you're on like anybody else's
opposer and and you know one thing that
I noticed looking at at the history of
the counterculture is almost every group
that came in thought the group that went
after them and the group that went
before them were posers and we're awful
so the hippies didn't much like the
beatniks and they really
hid the punks punks didn't much like the
hippies and they really hated the
hardcore kids so it's just been the
cycle I think of Bohemians hating each
other for a long time I guess the
constant turnover and the you know the
creative destruction of the culture of
st. Mark's is kind of what keeps it
vibrant would you agree with that I
think that that's true I think that it
really has stayed vibrant because
there's been so much turnover and then
and also when people get there they just
fell in love with it and they feel like
they own it and they feel sick it's
really a place that lets them become who
they were meant to be it's a real like
Forge for identities of young people
that's still true i think i want to talk
a little bit about the the mid to late
60s when andy warhol started throwing
his parties there and how did that go
over with the natives the natives didn't
like it they had no I think we see we
look back now and we can see who was
important to the culture and who was
wonderful and I think back then it was a
lot harder people to tell in the moment
and so I had people tell me that you
know they would see Andy Warhol walk
downstream they'd be like oh he's
ruining the neighborhood so mad because
you know they've missed it when it was
quieter and they missed it when it was
these little shops so during the 60s it
was a real hangout for artsy people and
you know creative people and then in
1967 there was a big violent horrible
murder of this hippie named groovy and
his girlfriend and they were you know
she was raped and he they were both
killed in a basement on Avenue B so not
very far from st. Mark's Place and once
that happened all the suburban kids were
basically forbidden from coming to hang
on st. Mark's Place anymore it wasn't
seen as this innocent you know fun you
know free love and drugs cut a magical
place anymore and so it became just a
breeding ground for crime and drugs and
it felt really quickly into disrepair so
the CBGB came Eric came out of that
because you had all these young people
who kind of like this guy's eNOS so they
showed up and there were all these free
or very cheap spaces for them so you
know that it was it was a real place for
them to live cheaply and to do what they
wanted to do which was to play this kind
of new kind of music young people would
move from the suburbs to st. marks and
they'd be seduced by the romance of
poverty and he specifically talked about
the legendary artist Keith Haring who
had lived in the city for two years
before he started putting up the street
art telling the clones to go home as a
born in bread st. Marq sir what do you
of people who are even from there
deciding what's authentic I mean I
always think it's really funny when
people anybody of any era and it's been
going on for a long time get to a place
and decide they know who belongs there
and that you know they're going to
defend it from all of these invaders who
are coming in and even now I see it and
I'll see people be like oh these stupid
NYU you know New York University kids
who are just like they're making so much
money and they are throwing his loud
parties and you know honestly like well
when did you get here and what do you
really think people's reaction to you
was because I can guarantee it probably
wasn't positive you know I'm actually I
had one woman who said to me she was
like you know these kids they just come
in here and there drinking and drugging
and being so loud and horrible and we
did that [ __ ] in the 70s sure but when
we did it it was cool no irony no no I
mean it's like a sweet how how everybody
believes that yeah and it's every
generation has like our grandparents
believe that and we believe that in our
grandchildren will believe that too so
can you talk a little bit about growing
up on st. Mark's Place cently it was the
80s yeah i was born in 1976 so it was
like the absolute worst time in the
streets history basically ever um and it
was really it was dangerous and dirty
and there were always homeless people
sleeping in the lobby and their people
nodding out on the corners and um but
you're smiling so I mean you know I live
as fine like I didn't know any better i
was a kid i thought it was totally
normal it wasn't until it was a little
older that I went to the suburbs for the
first time I wrote a story for the near
Times Magazine about it actually where I
went to kent ohio to visit my cousins
and I came back and I was like are you
kidding me what do you do you know what
they have like lawns and carpet and
you're just like all these things that I
never really seen before if you could
describe st. marks in one simple
sentence what it would be st. marks is
like the main street for the
counterculture and it's just it's always
been some place people ran to to find
other people like them and you think
that's still the case that I think it's
totally stole the case you go out at two
in the morning and it's still full of
young people and they're still having
this very magical experience thanks so
much for talking to us in a Calhoun the
author of st. marks is dead the many
lives of America's hippest street it's a
great book about the
cyclical nature of constant change of a
wonderful and ever countercultural
street in new york city thanks so much
for talking Rosie thanks for having me
the reason TV I'm Anthony Fisher
you